you know it's not easy flying a
superhero or either but it does have its
benefits at home just ask mark rock the
fact that you play the Hulk how does
that affect your dad status I mean your
stock has got to go up there's some over
me now they love it my daughter $1.00
he's like a baby Hulk you know and the
other one like um she was having some
stuff at school and I was like Bella you
know I hope you don't feel bad about
yourself she's like no I'm a really good
friend I'm really cute and nice and my
dad's all mark and wife sunrise are the
parents of three children they were with
them on the set in Australia where the
Ruffalo kids even got to appear in a
scene as background extras it was good
nobody everyone I invite the set but
like you can't wait to come to set
they're there for 20 minutes it's like
is this what you do all day oh my god
it's so tedious but yeah it's tedious
for you not for me
the whole team's up with Thor for the
sequel and Mark isn't the only one in
his family who admires the star playing
the Viking god of thunder my son is like
Chris Hemsworth his voice his voice yeah
I mean he's got it off he's funny he's
beautiful he's talented and he's a great
surfer I mean it's a little come on man
leave a little crumbs for the rest of us
mere earthlings
[Music]
you